wir sprechen jetzt über die klimakleber
die Aktivisten waren heute unterwegs an
den Flughäfen in München und in Berlin
Birgit Kelle sitzt hier und sagt wir
brauchen endlich härtere Strafen ihr
Thema ja heute haben wieder in München
und in Berlin Mitglieder der sogenannten
letzten Generation wobei man nur hoffen
kann dass das wirklich die letzte
Generation ist sich
illegal Zugang zum Flugfeld verschafft
mit dem Ziel den Flughafen lahm zu legen
und ist auch zumindest in München mal
kurz geschafft
ich denke es ist an der Zeit dass wir
diese jungen Straftäter genauso
behandeln wie wir jeden anderen
Straftäter auch behandeln würden wir
schauen uns die ganze Zeit schon an was
sie treiben zuerst waren das
Straßenblockaden dann waren das Angriffe
Sachbeschädigung auf Kunstwerke jetzt
sind das die Flughäfen man fragt sich
was nehmen sie sich als nächstes vor auf
ihrer Homepage steht dass sie die
öffentliche Ordnung stören wollen
ansonsten stört das aber in unserer
Bundesregierung offensichtlich niemanden
weil wir reden immer noch von Aktivisten
und von klimatern nein das sind
Straftäter auf den gefährlichen Eingriff
in den Flugverkehr kriegt man
normalerweise Gefängnis und ich würde
sie alle Bitten zu überlegen was ihnen
eigentlich passieren würde wenn sie
morgen versuchen einen Flughafen zu
entern mit dem Ziel in lahm zu legen wir
alle würde in den Bau gehen und genau
das denke ich sollten wir jetzt endlich
auch mit diesen Straftätern tun denn wir
würden es auch nicht dulden es geht
nicht um das Ziel es geht nicht darum
was sie eigentlich wollen denn wir
würden jeden Reichsbürger und jeden
Jungen rechtsradikalen würden wir
genauso in den Knast setzen und würden
nicht glauben heimliche Freude empfinden
also endlich alle Gesetze anwenden die
wir haben Herr Schall ich glaube wir
können offen drüber reden sie waren
kriminell in ihrer Jugend haben härtere
Strafe aber ein härtere Straßen sie
abgehalten davon ist das etwas was einen
also es kommt darauf wann du die
härteren Strafen erlebst umso und das
ist nämlich das entscheidende wenn du
sie gleich früh erlebst haben sie eine
abschreckende Wirkung wenn du aber lange
damit durchkommst dann lernst du im
Knast nur welche kennen mit denen du
noch Geschäfte planst bei denen ist es
so dass merkt man immer wieder den geht
es vor allen Dingen um ihre eigene
Wirkung und ihr Klickzahlen und da sind
wir wieder bei dem Thema linkes und
grünes Auge blickt das ist ja der
verlängerte Arm auf der grünen und ich
frage mich ob sie schon mehrfach
gefordert wo ist eigentlich die
Distanzierung der Grünen von dieser von
diesen Herren und Damen und immer wieder
man muss sich vorstellen was sind wir
eigentlich für eine Bananen Republik ich
meine da können die sich auf dem
Flugzeug Platz in Flughafen in Berlin
und dort
Zutritt gewähren sie können sich da
feststellen sie können machen was sie
wollen und sie sagen ja wir werden immer
mehr machen nur noch mal zur Erinnerung
wurde hier gerade in Berlin ist eine
Frau unter einem und ein LKW geraten und
die Rettungsfahrzeuge kam zu spät ob sie
noch leben könnte oder nicht aber es
wurde gesagt es hat auf jeden Fall die
Zeit minimiert und einer dieser Gruppe
hat gesagt Mann wir sind hier im klimake
Weg nicht Klima kuscheln ja und da frage
ich mich wo soll das hinführen für mich
sind das kriminelle ich war kriminell
das ist kriminelle Handlung man greift
in die innere Sicherheit ein und wenn
ich dann aber ein Herrn Gysi der wird
natürlich auch natürlich ganz aus
eigenem unnot tut sich hinstellt und
diese Leute da vertritt und sagt setzen
Sie ein Zeichen sprechen Sie diese Leute
frei die kämpfen ja für die Freiheit und
dann und ich bin übrigens seit
neuneinhalb Jahren Aktivist ich habe
noch so fest geklebt habe keine innere
Sicherheit bedroht okay keine fahrausübt
aber der 915 Kinderschutz und dann waren
die sich
Klima und Kinder in einem Atemzug zu
nehmen machen aber nichts gegen
Missbrauch machen nichts gegen Mobby und
Gewalt und da für die Zukunft der Kinder
wagt euch nicht die Kinder mit diesen
Dingen zusammen damit zu bringen ihr tut
ein Scheißdreck für die Kinder es geht
doch um euch und dann fahrt ihr noch mit
Autos dahin was für eine verlogene
Heuchlerei wen wollt ihr eigentlich
verarschen und noch mal Probe es sind
ihre
ideologischen Freunde ich fordere Sie
jetzt Außenministerin auf und auch ein
Habicht hier endlich ist Statement zu
machen das wird nicht wolltest mir schon
klar weil natürlich eure Wähler sind und
die wieder dranhängen aber es geht um
die innere Sicherheit ihr wollte den Job
dann macht ihn oder legt dann am
Niederwald so fördert ihr innere
Unsicherheit und gefährdet unser Land
alle durchweg was sie zu sagen haben
schauen wir mal auf die Gründe warum man
sich dort
habe ich jetzt leider hier gerade nicht
zu bieten
tue das weil die Regierung nicht genug
handelt die Regierung hat die Krise
nicht im Griff und alle anderen Methoden
sind leider ausgeführt ich habe auch
keine Lust das hier zu machen und ich
weiß dass viele Leute das nicht
verstehen werden aber wir haben keine
andere Wahl mehr
ich weiß auch dass ich hierfür
vielleicht auch wieder im Gefängnis
Lande wo ich vorher schon war wo jetzt
gerade vier Leute sind zwei davon bis
zum 5
und ich habe keine Lust Weihnachten im
Gefängnis zu verbringen ich habe keine
Lust neuer im Gefängnis zu verbringen
ich möchte auch lieber bei meiner
Familie sein aber die Lage drängt
Herr Schmiel wenn Sie Malte zuhören
spüren sie da die Verzweiflung
vielleicht können Sie mal den Versuch
wagen und diese Generation zu erklären
also ferndiagnostik ist immer schwierig
an einem einzelnen Video Beleg mich
irritieren nur die Zahlen dass sie schon
wieder am 5 Januar draußen sind die über
die ja da gesprochen hat also halt also
das ist so natürlich ist diese
Generation verzweifelt natürlich hat
diese Generation auch ein emotionalen
Druck nur es war noch nie der Fall dass
die Schädigung von unbeteiligter zu
einer sinnvollen Diskussion führen das
funktioniert nicht das ist genauso wenn
man jetzt einfach weil man für ein
Kinderschutz Eintritt irgendwo hingehen
und ein paar Leuten vor die Klappe
halten oder andere Dinge verhindert das
hilft ja nicht für den Prozess und man
merkt ja auch ich bin selber kein Auto
finden viele Sachen innerlich passiert
toll aber man entwickelt ja eine
Antipathie plötzlich aufgrund dieser
Maßnahmen und deshalb kippt dieser
Prozess gerade in die falsche Richtung
deshalb kann man sagen überlegt euch
etwas was förderlich ist wo ihr das das
Wohlwollen der Gesellschaft auf euch
zieht anstelle sozusagen die Wut von
allen und wenn dann auch noch
Menschenleben dabei ums betroffen sind
dann ist ein Zeitpunkt gegeben da muss
einfach mit anderen Bedingungen
einhergegangen werden das Problem also
wenn ich dann höre es geht ja auch nicht
nur um die Bundesregierung die wo ich
denke eben die lassen das ja auch
gewähren weil sie klamm heimlich damit
auf sympathisieren weil man ja genau
genommen sozusagen hier diese Kinder
jetzt auf dem Rollfeld die Arbeit machen
um die Politik zu rechtfertigen die man
dann im Bundestag beschließen will mich
irritiert viel mehr wenn selbst der
Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes
irgendwie sagt ja nee nee gegen die
gegen die letzte Generation muss man
eigentlich die muss man nicht beobachten
das sind ja nicht Extremisten ja also
wir haben jetzt gerade eine Woche hinter
uns wo wir irgendwie eine Rollstuhl
Armee mit 3000 Polizisten haben wir ein
paar Rentner in Maßanzügen verhaftet
irgendwie weil die anderen Bundestag
eventuell stürmen ist Wunder auch Waffen
gehören möglicherweise legale Waffen wir
wissen noch nicht ob das illegale Waffen
ich will nur sagen wir sind also ein
Land das 3000 Polizisten in Gang setzt
irgendwie zum einen um einen Royalisten
der gerne sein Reich zurückhaben möchte
irgendwie festzunehmen was was halt
grenzwertig ist ich verlange nur dass
der Verfassungsschutz sich dann
bitteschön genauso mit einer jungen
Generation befasst die jetzt schon
bereit ist Sachbeschädigung zu machen
Hausfriedensbruch zu machen die auf
ihrer Homepage ankündigt dass sie die
öffentliche Ordnung stören will und zwar
so lange bis die Regierung das tut was
sie will Nötigung oder Pressung ist das
ist Nötigung oder Pressung
Straftaten die begangen werden und wir
leben mit einem Land wo man sagt ja da
muss man Verständnis sein nein sorry ich
habe null Verständnis ich habe übrigens
in einem Flieger gesessen als sie das
erste Mal beim ber drin waren und ich
habe zwei Stunden im Flieger gesessen
weil die auf dem Rollfeld klebten und
das nächste mal irgendwie will ich dir
am liebsten selber vom Rollstuhl wieder
runterkratzen ich habe keinen
Verständnis und wir dürfen genau
genommen in einem Rechtsstand auch gar
nicht in dem Sinne mit Verständnis
arbeiten weil es nämlich egal ist aus
welcher Motivation heraus das passiert
wir sind vor dem Gesetz alle gleich ja
und wer eben wie soll ich sagen man muss
nur einmal theoretisch durch denken wenn
das jetzt nicht die klimakleber wären
auf dem Rollfeld sondern die
Reichsbürger wären dann hier alle
genauso entspannt und wäre unsere
Regierung genauso entspannt wenn jetzt
plötzlich Reichsbürger mit ihrem
Rollator auf unserem Rollfeld auftauchen
und sagen wir machen den Putsch jetzt
auf dem Rollfeld nein dann werden alle
so oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ja das
heißt wir wir messen auch hier wieder
mit zweierlei Maß weil man heimlich
sympathisiert mit dieser Bewegung ja
während man an anderer Stelle mit aller
Härte des Gesetzes Durchgang auch hier
sage ich ich will gar keine
Sonderbehandlung ich will dass die
Sonderbehandlung aufhört wir wollen hier
ja vor allem auch verstehen warum
Menschen sowas machen warum sie diesen
Weg wählen können Probleme haben kann
keine ernsten Probleme also muss man
wirklich sagen das ist
wenn man sich die Sorgen anguckt die
Nummer die Klimaentwicklung aus Sicht
dieser Generation mit sich bringt und
sie das Gefühl haben die Versäumnisse
der Politik wenn man bestimmte Ziele
vereinbart die gemeinsam vereinbart
werden und Ziele sind nie erreicht
werden und alle Bemühungen nicht ernst
genommen werden dass dann jemand auf die
Straße geht das haben wir als wir gegen
die Abrüstung also für die Abrüstung die
demonstriert dann sind wir auch auf die
Straße gegangen und haben uns sichtbar
gemacht aber du hast du hast eine Demo
angemeldet das war alles legal da hat
das Recht haben wir auch genau das ist
zum Beispiel ich mache seit 9 Jahre
Kinderschutz wenn ich mich auf der
Straße festgeklebt hätte oder sonst seid
ihr macht das ich wäre sofort im Bau
gegangen hätten Exempel statuiert dass
ich mir nie wieder wage ich finde es
okay dass sie sich feststellen klebt
euch am Bundestag fest klebt dich an
Lauterbach oder Scholz Fest hat dann
morgen sowieso wieder vergessen mach
bitte aber lass die dort auch mit der
Nötigung ihr wollt ihr klimaschützen
dann hat die Leute auf zu erpressen ihr
nötig die Menschen und der Hass wird
steigen ist wie mit dem gleichen ist
ungleiche wenn sie nicht darüber reden
welche fehlende Migration hier
stattfindet und Kirche gefahren sind
fördern sie damit hast wenn sie
totschweigen und genau das ist das hier
aber es ist der verlängerte gerillahah
der Grünen und deswegen würde erreichen
Sie die Menschen noch erreichen Sie die
die sich auf die Straße kleben kleben
wir wie Herr Schmied sagt die Hoffnung
das Vertrauen die Perspektive verloren
hat also ich glaube die die auf der
Straße kleben die erreicht die Politik
nicht das ist ja auch verständlich die
wollen ja selbstverständlich das ist
eine kleine Gruppe muss man ja sagen von
30 sehr stark radikalisierten Personen
und die wird man auch nicht erreichen
die muss man eben mit rechtsstaatlichen
Mitteln auch in den Griff bekommen das
ist ähm ja Moment es ist nicht ganz also
ich wenn man also sich auf die Straße
klebt und sagt ich verlange von der
Politik dass sie einen Busticket
bundesweit für 9 € einführt ja und und
bis es fertig ist klebe ich mich nicht
los ja das geht einfach nicht das jeder
weiß dass sowas nicht funktioniert weil
dann setzt sich der nächste und ich will
kostenlos Bier und ich will Äpfel und
ich hätte gern ein Haus für 9 €. das
wird nicht funktionieren deswegen muss
ja auch die Politik da durchgreifen wir
haben zwei ganz einfache Vorschläge
gemacht das eine ist was am ersten Mai
gut funktioniert das Verfahren manche
von diesen Tätern haben schon 30 Mal
geklebt bis jetzt 30 mal 30 Leute sind
30 Mal gesehen warum sind heute wieder
zwei flughäfenlagen der Punkt weil eben
keine beschleunigten Verfahren
durchgeführt werden so dass man die auch
mal bei wiederholungstage etwas länger
in Haft nehmen könnte beispielsweise ja
es geht ja darum einmal strafrechtlich
gegen sie vorzugehen und dann der zweite
Vorschlag den auch die FDP gemacht hat
war wir wollen eine
schadensersatzplattform wo die Bürger
das sind ja hunderttausende die jeden
Tag davon betroffen sind wo die Bürger
die materielle Schäden erleiden z.B weil
sie mit dem Mietwagen gerade weiß ich
von einem Carsharing fliegen können wenn
sie den gewohnt haben
Geschäftstermin verpassen ähnliches da
entstehen Kosten und die müssten durch
so eine Plattform wie bei
Fluggastrechten einfach geltend gemacht
werden können das könnten nicht alle
machen aber das wären vielleicht pro
Stau 20 30.000 € und dann würden nämlich
die Finanzströme die momentan eben das
ganze tragen weil die kriegen ja auch
noch Geld aus Inland und Ausland die
sammeln Spenden und darüber finanziert
sich das alles das müsste man sich
ansehen das wäre ganz dringend nur das
Problem ist wir haben bei Grünen und
Linken da beißen wir auf Granit an der
Stelle in Berlin ein rot-grün-roter
Senat haben überhaupt kein Interesse
daran beschleunigt das Verfahren
schadensersatzplattform alles abgelehnt
und das ist das Problem wir brauchen ein
konsequentes Vorgehen die Vorschläge
liegen auf dem Tisch man könnte es auch
machen aber es wird Stillschweigen
toleriert und das geht nicht genau das
ist aber das einzige das ist in genau
das Kernproblem ist es wird toleriert ja
wir haben sozusagen es gibt genug oder
zu viele Leute in diesem Land die
Verständnis haben dafür und deswegen
eben und genau darauf können die auch
bauen und genau genommen irgendwie es
lohnt gar nicht darüber zu diskutieren
ob die reden wollen weil genau genommen
wenn die reden wollten dann würden die
dann würden sie schauen dass sie sich in
den demokratischen Prozess einteilen
einschalten aber genau das tun sie auch
nicht ja also um den lieben malte zu
zitieren er sagt alle anderen Methoden
sind ausgeschöpft welche Methoden bitte
schön hat in der Liebe malte schon
ausgeschöpft ja ähm was kommt danach
nein nein
teilweise Entwicklung der 70er Jahren
der RAF so hat übrigens der liebe Herr
Müller Tacho Müller auch gesagt wir
haben so ein bisschen verniedlich als
grüne RAF so verniedlicht wenn man
solche Dinge schon hört frage ich mich
wohin soll das führen und genau davor
was ist denn das nächste Ziel genau wie
radikalisieren sich dann und dann sagt
der Verfassungsschutz schlimm oder Herr
Gisi um sich selbst zu profilieren
profilieren sagt oh sprechen sie mein
Grundsatz Urteil die sind doch gar nicht
so böse aber wisst er nur nebenbei
marcelotte ich und tischis haben wir
dafür gesorgt das sind Berlin neuwahlen
sind ja aber dafür gesorgt dass die
Demokratie geschützt wird das kam mir
jetzt alles raus also haben wir ja in
Berlin die Möglichkeit neu zu wählen und
vielleicht kapiert jetzt der eine oder
andere der nicht gewählt hat oder der
vielleicht denkt durchlebt wenn man
anders dass man jetzt in Berlin einen
solchen Tod Schweiger und kriminellen
Unterstützer sehen hat der nicht mal
seine Opfer entschädigt von
Kindesmissbrauch wo sie sich 30 Jahre
mit schuldig gemacht haben entschädigt
vielleicht mal anders wird wenn nur ein
kleiner Hinweis ist wir haben ja auch
dafür getan um die Demokratie zu
schützen das hier seine Gefährdung der
Demokratie und nochmal linkes Auge und
grünes Auge blind wir machen den Mund
auf es reicht